[inaudible]
let's shift, let's talk about the
scary you right. Are you ready?
I tried to do this. We did
the happy stuff. Now we're
going to plunge with, look,
you know, Dave, when I began
to research this thing,
I probably ended up reading about 200
books on this topic when the end and,
and I'm a happy guy. I like happy things.
I like technology. I'm an optimistic guy,
but this really put me in
a dark place. Uh, digging
through this history, uh, from,
from Hagle essentially up to
Julius Caesar Eveleigh and the,
and the post were Nazi movement and
realizing that there was an intellectual
stream that stretched
over all of these years.
Let's go back 200 years.
Yeah.
So let's go back 200 years when you
talk about right wing collectivism.
Yeah.
Because I think most of my audience now
understands what left wing collectivism
is cause that's what we've got right now.
Very in a very strong way.
Talk to me about right wing
collectivism. Okay, Dave,
I'm going to tell you a story.
Um, I, I love Ludi muses.
I think he was a genius, right? And
I thought I'd read all of his works,
but in there is a transcript of a lecture
he gave in 1956 at the San Francisco
Public Library.
And he had about three sentences in
there that just knocked me over and I
couldn't believe it.
It cause it explains so much.
He says something like this and he's
speaking casually, right? He says,
Hagle ruined German
philosophy for a century. Uh,
his original followers became,
uh,
believed that all of history
would end in the Prussian state,
in the Prussian church, having all power
in the individuality, individualism,
they became the right Hegelians.
Galleons that became the Nazis
is the dissonance of this,
uh, of the writer.
Gillian's became the lefty.
Gillian's they wanted a universal
transformation of humanity and a,
and a historical drive to, to something
other than the commercial society.
They became the Marxists
and, uh, and the communists.
And he said that that's, it's
left, right yelling aneurysm.
And that explains pretty much
all political history. And
I closed that. I thought,
hmm,
that explains more than practically
any other book I've ever read.
And so I began to,
began to explore this.
I understood the left to Galleon as I
understood Marxism. I mean, those were,
those were our professors, right?
Um, and there are annoying.
Um, but what I did not understand what
the writer Gillion of them and what that,
what that tradition looks like.
It's the throne and alter, uh, this,
this historic says to view that the
nation should constitute its own unit of
profound integrity, uh, that, that
that is more important than the,
than the individual. And that commercial
society was too chaotic. That it,
that that was leading us,
giving us wrong kind of progress.
That it was flattening out the hierarchies
that we need to have an orderly life.
Right?
This is,
this is the writer Gelien
pitch that ultimately by mid
20th century becomes this
very dangerous, dangerous
movement in Europe. You know, um,
that became catastrophic.
Uh,
but it gradually emerged from all
the way from, from Hagle because,
uh,
this is at the end of the endless,
seemingly in those Franco Prussian wars.
There's this battle at the battle
of Jenna that, that Germany lost.
And the explanation for that was
that it was a temporary setback.
That history was going to determine
that Germany would rise despite,
despite the choices of individuals.
History has got its wind.
It's like a Meta narrative that, that,
that was going to override everything.
Hegel himself was a theologian
by the way. Um, and, and so this,
this view began to kind of spread
throughout German academia. And it was,
it ended up being imported
to the United States through,
through circuitous means, but what,
but one of the great theorists of the,
of the 1840 [inaudible] who, and 1850s
who brought the suit to the United States,
there's physical list,
who was one of the first economist to
repudiate the free trade tradition of, of,
of the Smithian Manchester Rides.
And that was celebrating the nation as a,
as a unit, as a productive power, uh, and,
and believed in tariff
walls, uh, which was strange.
And I've read his book, uh, but,
and that had a huge influence of American
trade policy is actually the late 19th
century. And, um,
and it began to flow out from there.
So Thomas Carlyle and,
and Britain now,
uh,
began to celebrate the
great man theory of history.
And really we're nothing without Napoleon,
without,
without gigantic of figures
that we can worship, admire,
and s and our individuality
should be subsumed within them.
They act for us. They're God,
like, you know, and, and,
and it was Thomas Carlyle who
first coined the phrase, um,
uh,
quite coin,
the phrase to describe economics
as being the dismal science.
And the reason he said that is that
every condoms team new imagined a world
without slavery. And he said,
kind of have a website slavery.
That's a tread for world without
slaves. You don't have masters, right?
And we need a world with
masters and slaves, so we can,
we can have a vision of hierarchy
and greatness without that,
we don't have greatness.
So he began to see this building of
this intellectual apparatus that was not
left together.
And there wasn't Marxist who was
actually anti Marxist in a strange way,
but as an alternative
form of collectivism, uh,
it began with a kind of historicism
and a celebration on nationalism of the
German state.
It began to grow with this,
this alternative theory
of trade that we should,
we should build up tariff
walls and Carlisle with his,
with his great man theory of
history and then, and then, uh,
Rueskin and Britain with his haste
hatred of Commercial Society because they
believed that somehow,
uh,
commerce was ruining quality and culture
and was giving us mass production.
But we all need to be really
doing is, is, is, uh, uh,
living in guilds and, and
making our own stuff, you know,
because we're going to destroy English
life and English country life. And so, so,
uh, a full scale reactionary trend
on the right began to develop.
And were you always a
racial element to know?
So that's what's interesting.
I'm so glad you asked that because
it comes about first of all, through,
through nationalism now and the,
and the early 1820s and 1830s,
this celebration of nationalism.
Now you have to ask yourself,
what is a nation, Bret,
what do we mean when we say nation?
And,
and I'm taking this a lot
of this from, um, uh, from,
uh, uh, an essay gave it,
given the 1882 by Erin ran in
a great French historian. Uh,
looking back at the rise
of nationalism said,
there's only five ways you can consider
nationalism. Uh, you consider, uh,
the geographic definition.
So we're just live in this space.
There's a dynastic element.
We can all trace our lineage back
to the great founders of our nation.
There's a language theory of nationals
and we all speak the same language.
There's a religious theory of nationalism.
We all worship God and it precisely the
same way I believe in transubstantiation.
You believe in consubstantiation,
we can't be part of the same nation
and that case, right? And then finally,
and probably most insidiously, there
was the ratio, the ratio of view.
And that came along and
essentially the 1860s and 1870s,
with a misapplication of Darwinian
theory and scientific racism came along.
And that's wept through academia,
particularly in the United States.
Like nothing you've ever seen.
It's absolutely astonishing
how much racism with Orthodoxy
and American academia
in the 1890 [inaudible],
the very first monograph
published by the American economy,
Economic Association by gay men,
I think his name is Andre Hoffman.
It was called race traits
of the American Negro.
And the first chapter dress goes all
in. You know, it's, it's, it's the,
the horror of the black people that
don't have the right values. They can't,
can't save money.
They're just terrible.
A shiftless and lazy and
ghastly and uncivilized double.
And now chapter two, the Jews, you
know, these people, I don't know what,
they've got this crazy out
of control commercial ethic.
They can't stop hoarding money.
They really went for it. Yeah. And then
the third chapter three is the slops and,
and so on. And so the American Economic
Association, you know, and then, uh,
and there was essentially, no, what do you
think was happening in the world there?
That it was taking a time,
what was happening? Dave?
Laissez faire had transformed societies
so dramatically that there the
intellectuals felt that
they had lost control.
And that you might think that when the
world becomes massively prosperous and we
suddenly have cities rising up and we've
got steel that is transverse in large
bodies of water and we're developing the
telephone and indoor electricity and,
and people are living longer lives and,
and so much wealth was being created
that everybody was data per say. Hooray.
We found the answers.
But the gatekeepers who had
controlled everything for so long.
So that's so interesting
because of revolt.
This is sort of what it feels
like now to me, the gatekeepers,
we've had so much success.
There's so,
there's so many reasons right now to
understand how great everything is.
That book right there by
Steven Pinker enlightenment is,
is all about how great things are.
And a gratefully we are,
there is less violence now and all sorts
of the revolt you always have to be on
the gatekeepers are having,
are not in the narrative to intellectuals
are what digital closet calls the
clerisy. Right? So it's, it's
the high end intellectuals,
it's the power elite bureaucrats in the,
in the public,
the permanent peace keepers of
our civic culture. You know, it's,
it's the political class. And, uh,
so this is sort of what for my
audience that maybe not follow this,
this is sort of what the New York Times
is sort of, right. But like, yeah,
maybe I shouldn't have said
it so obviously, but like
that's kind of what it is.
Like that class, the ruling
class. Yeah. The ruling class.
And they were in full scale revolted.
They did not like what was happening
to the world and the 18, 80s and 90s,
because of the loss of control.
And so the,
the scientific racism came along to add
to the celebration of dictatorship and
the,
and the,
and protectionism and the new nationalism
to add a very insidious element,
which culminated in Eugenics ideology.
And that's when it gets very strange.
And this is where,
this is where the reading
gets very difficult because
now you're reading all the
way into, uh, you know, the, the, the
1910s with the works of Oswald Spangler,
you know, the right, who galleon German
theorist that enraptured every American,
you know, they're all reading his book.
Oh my God. The decline of the West.
We better reconstitute
ourselves as the tribe,
or we're going to be eaten alive by
flood out the other foreigners and then,
but there's a strain of that that's
still going on right now. You know,
there's nothing new, you know,
like, um, and you know, this,
this very funny book called the passing
of the great race by Madison Grant,
uh,
that was on every coffee table in
the late 19 teens and early 19th,
20th, you know, with this forecasting doom
for the white race. You know, and he was,
he was a fascinating figure because, um,
you know, of course I've read his book as,
as it everybody did. Everybody the great
Gatsby makes a pass in reference to it.
It was that popular. It was
that popular. And I tell you,
there's not a single outright
racist alive today who hasn't,
is not repeating those cliches that
were written by Madison Grant has all
pseudoscience is all just nonsense. And
it's just ridiculous. Embarrassing. But,
but it keeps being resurrected.
But here's what's interesting.
He was a thoroughgoing a Darwinian,
because you recall that Darwin,
Darwin had two great books,
origin these pieces.
The other was called the descent of man.
And the descent of man had the very
unfortunate paragraph in there where he
regret regrets. Um, the
invention of mass, uh,
disease killing, uh, uh,
uh, cures essentially.
It's like if we keep curing people and
we keep feeding a inferior people and,
and curing disease,
then then our genetic stock students
kind of go down and down, you know, so,
so they were all kind of playing
off this little, the passage.
But Madison Grant was,
was not an unusual by American x to
academic standards at all. They, they,
this was orthodox in the 18,
Tencent 1820s.
What made Madison Grant Interesting?
You can look up his Wikipedia entry
right now. Uh, if you look it up, it'll,
it'll celebrate him as the, as the
father of the National Park Service.
Well,
in the course of my research,
I'm wondering to know what
is the connection between
Madison's grants hardcore
eugenics based racism and as
environmentalist them? Hmm.
What is the relationship there? And it's
not just two people usually people have,
have it figured out in their own heads.
I went through and read some of
his works on, on the environment.
It turns out that he had a
master race theory of nature,
and he went to the California redwoods
and he looked at these glorious mighty
trees and he was horrified to see
they're being cut down for, for, for,
for making coffee tables and
boats and things like that.
And he thought it was dis genic to nature.
So he wanted the master race,
uh, the California redwoods to
be protected. And that's that.
So that's why he started
the national park service.
And now the left Harold's them as,
as, as great as a great visionary,
environmentalist.
But actually he was like a tree Nazi.
I don't know how else you want to call.
It's very creepy stuff. We
don't have enough Nazi labels
being thrown around now.
We're going to have tree nuts even. Sure.
That already was nuts. Um, but you know,
you can just march through the
history and it gets worse and worse.
And then to me, Dave, it'll, it all
culminates in the works of Karl Schmidt,
uh, from the, from the late 1930s and his,
and his amazing book called
the concept of the political.
And if you'll give me just one quick
second to explain this, because,
because you as a liberal,
uh,
need to read this book because it's
the most passionate, I would say,
and even competent attack on liberalism
Britain in the 20th century. Now,
Carl Schmidt,
that's a jurist of brilliant man and a
philosopher and a hardcore Nazi. Okay.
He wasn't tried at Nuremberg. He escape.
I'm merely an intellectual. Okay, sure.
His book concepts with the political says,
what's wrong with liberalism?
I tell you, it's still nothing
happens, nothing dramatic.
There's nothing requires
no courage whatsoever.
Liberalism is a life in which we all
benefit from each other's presence.
We all just trade with each other.
What kind of life is that where we all
just are kind of the same and like each
other and hold backyard barbecues
and go baseball games and,
and just get richer and live longer
lives and send our kid to college.
This is terrible. We need
to live big, dramatic,
mighty, bold, courageous,
transformative lives and live in
times that, that, that, that, that,
that are shocking, that are amazing,
that make our lives worth living,
that requires above all else politics.
Liberalism imagines a world without
politics. That's a terrifying world.
What we need is a world of politics and,
and he continues to lay
it out chapter by chapter.
Why we have to destroy the liberalism and
celebrate the concept of the political
and for him that means having friends
and having enemies defeating your enemies
and rallying around your friends.
Now who are your friends and who
your enemies and Carl Schmidt says,
at some level,
it doesn't matter.
What matters is that
they exist and the state,
the powerful men will choose them for us.
They will decide who our
friends and our enemies are.
Now let's be clear what we mean by enemy.
I don't don't mean
somebody you don't like.
I mean the willingness to kill there has
to be the presence of real bloodshed in
your time. For you to have a
sufficiently prescient sense of enemies,
this so that you'll feel the intense
desire to rally around your fence for your
friends and experience
that, that, that the,
the awesomeness that only comes
with belonging to a group. So,
so he says,
so he,
at the end feeling there is
that you can't achieve what,
what the real purpose of a human is that
you can experience whatever the highs
of belongingness essentially,
and the life of drama that a big important
life without being part of a kind of
a, uh, a group on the move, the
slaughtering and its enemies.
And so we have to have the presence of,
of bloodshed.
So it really is the opposite of live and
let live. It is. It's so through, through,
through bloodshed comes life and without,
without bloodshed and death
and violence in politics,
then you're just going to live at an
irrelevant life. And we can't have that.
So he was in many ways the philosophical
architect of the Holocaust. Again,
not a leftist, not a Marxist,
although he dabbled in it.
You find that so from a lot of these,
right?
Collectivists the writing galleons that
they dabbled. Guys like Verner some Bart,
right? He was once a communist
who later became a Nazi.
Carl Schmitt dabbled in and leftism
and then went full. Right? Um,
and it was in many ways the culmination
of the writing galleon ideology in
crossfit. So it's a book worth
reading and contemplating.
And I would say to anybody who
rejects liberalism, you know,
be honest about where
you're going with this.
This is the opposite of the celebration
of death in the quirks of crush Schmidt,
very powerful thinker,
highly regarded,
even today worth reading
and worth reflecting on what
kind of world do you want
to live in to live in peace with others.
Where do you want a slot at your friends,
a slaughter your enemies
and rally with your friends.
So move me from that point
1930s into of course,
obviously into Nazi Germany and, and then
we'll, we'll finish where we, yeah, and,
and you know, my book really does it
1958 not necessarily. It didn't have to,
but I started to get really queasy
about what happened after World War II.
A lot of the writing Gelien movement
went underground, you know, um,
and,
and became a kind of a,
a quiet neo Nazi movement that never
really had access to social media that
clearly weren't in
academia, obviously. And,
but the ideology never entirely went
away. And, and it was just lying in, wait,
wait,
waiting for the failure of the left and
for the resentment of the population
against the left to rise up
and receive would get a fever.
It enough pitch that it would, it
would then, ah, come on full force.
And that's really what's happening
in Europe. Russia, United States,
it's an alternative form of
collectivism has got a different flavor,
a different orientation,
a different kind of resentments,
but it's still drags in this gigantic
history of writing Ghillean ideology,
the celebration of the Dick, great
man, dictator, the protectionism,
the anti-immigration,
the nativism,
the nationalism that could take any one
of five forms, including the racism. Um,
what do you make about how now,
and it's obviously largely
because of the Internet.
It seems to be happening in so many
places at once. We're seeing this unholy.
It's an oddly unholy alliance between
the collectivists left and then that
drives it made.
It's exactly what you're saying.
Then you've got this other thing that's
just waiting there for these guys to go
to bananas. I was like, oh,
we got all these answers.
Meanwhile you have the
liberals and everyone,
all the decent 80% of us that
are trying to live and let live.
Part of it really comes down to this.
There's a weird sociological,
cultural contradiction at the heart
of social democratic leftist ideology.
On one hand they,
they wanted to build gigantic institutions
that are redistributed worry and
we're supposed to treat each other like
a big family and we're supposed to have
this homogeneous nation state and the
other hand they're celebrating diversity
and encouraging mass immigration and
heterogeneous populations, and guess what?
Those don't really work together.
So you build gigantic institute,
gigantic states that presume sort
of that we're all one family.
And then you throw in this,
this, this diverse set of people,
especially with the refugee crisis in
Europe and immigration in the United
States, and people are looking around
going down these people at my family,
I don't even like these. Yeah. And yet I'm
paying for them. That is a prescription.
I mean that, that blows up. I'm,
that's a disaster. It's a powder keg.
And so it was the left and there's
this core contradiction that they have
between on a welfare state on one hand,
and there's celebration and Hetero
heterogeneous populations on the other
welfare state and diversity.
They don't, they don't work.
And that basically puts us where
Germany sort of is at right now, right.
Where they said, okay, 3
million people come on in.
Now all these people are
going to have to pay for you.
We're not going to integrate you properly.
I mean, this is not only, you know,
you've got that I did to Terrian movements
rising up in Germany and in Hungary
and of course in Russia in,
and of course the US, you know,
so it all just kind of follows. It's,
it's inevitable. The left created this,
I mean, if, if after World War II
we had just embraced liberalism by,
we should have, like, we should have,
we wouldn't be where we are today,
but we have another chance. And that's
why you're here. And that's why I'm here.
We have another chance now to,
to re-embrace liberal liberal theory
and to, and to reject the left are,
and don't feel yourself just because
of the enemy of your enemy is there.
It doesn't mean it has to be your friend.
I mean,
we really do need to think of
ourselves as kind of a, uh,
dissidence from a political culture that,
that rally around freedom and human
rights and universal human rights and,
and the noble meant of humanity, the
champion of the common person, uh,
the rights of everyone to live
freely with each other, to,
to gain value from each other. And to
live in peace and stop thinking of our,
of our fellow human beings
as possible enemies.
We don't want to get drafted into this,
the political world that call Schmidt.
Imagine for us, as I was
describing crossfit, you,
you see it happening, right?
That Schmitty in view to slice and
dice the population. Who Do you like?
Who Do you hate? You know who
is, who are your people? It's,
this is not a good life. Yeah. And we feel
like chopping away at both sides, right?
Yeah, we do. We feel it. And so we don't,
I just don't feel like we have to be
part of it. I mean, as best we can, uh,
let's find things we love,
you know, and go places.
We love me with people who love
of all different backgrounds,
all different kinds of cultures. Learn
about alternative religions, learn,
learn about new ways to do things,
travel, right? And the age of liberalism,
there were no such things as passports,
you know? All right, so let's,
let's spend the last portion here on
just these last five years really here in
America, because I remember just even, it
doesn't have to be the last five years,
but let's say even three years ago,
just,
it's sort of the emergence of Trump as
a candidate when people started saying
the phrase, all right. Yeah.
And I did a bunch of videos on
it where I was basically saying,
I see two strains to this thing and people
are now using this video against me.
And what I saw was there was the
sort of fun money makers and the,
all of the people who were having fun
online doing often doing awful things and
Nazi imagery just to upset
people in power and whatever.
But sometimes very fun things too.
And funny things.
But I saw it like just the real sort of
shit posters as they're known in the pet
pay people.
The whole idea was we could get,
we can start sending a frog to some like
intellectual and they're gonna think
that's a racist thing. And then
they would, they would say,
I'm being under attack from racist.
Like they would actually give them
exactly what they want it. So I saw this,
this sort of fun shit
posting whatever part of it.
Not to say it didn't have elements
I didn't like, but there were,
I saw that as the bulk of it.
And then alongside of that,
was this that you're talking about the
identitarian part, the true racist part,
the part that had been sort of underground
for a long time and then because of
social media now is finding that it could,
yeah.
Actually you influence people and beat
it up. Okay. And now and you know,
and I think the media really fueled both
of those things because basically when
Hillary said that deplorables comment,
she,
she just lumped the whole
damn thing together.
And I think if she had not said that,
I think it's very
possible she be president.
Aoun should help the Kashi
almost made though. Right? Exist.
So my question really is, how would
you just define the alt right flat out?
If I asked you right now, because I think
the definition has changed and has it,
but if I asked you right now, in, in
the summer of 2018 the definition, you,
the phrase all right, comes
about what, 10 years ago,
I think it was coined by Paul God prayed
who himself as a follower of met. Yeah.
Um, I, I would rather
look at this as a, as,
as a writer, Galleon collectivist
movement, you know, and,
and general that stretches from the
early 19th century all the way up to the
present that's characterized by love
of dictatorship, a love of power,
protectionist trade policy, nativist
immigration policy and [inaudible],
and a resentment against the commercial
life because it's because it's, it's,
it's too heterogeneous into an ennobling
of humanity. I mean that too. To me,
the alt right is one species, I
guess you could say. One flavoring,
one instanciation yeah.
Of a much larger problem
that stretches way back,
which is an illiberal theory of,
of life in liberal theory of, of,
um, of, of politics. So that's, I
think the right way to think about it.
My first time I heard Trump
speak was July, 2015 and,
and I don't even think we were using
the term alt right at the time,
but he opened his speech with,
um, the immigrants are a problem.
I thought,
hmm.
Then there was protection of their foreign
goods protections when you protection
some. I thought, hmm, that's third
big point was I can fix everything.
This is all sounding strangely
familiar to me. You know, that's,
that's like the three pillars of a writer
Galleon ideology essentially. And, um,
I realized we had a problem
and I understand, I do,
why people had a high regard for him.
He was going to save us from,
from the problems that Obama had created.
And God knows those problems. And, and
the left has gotten just bonkers, right?
So we need,
we need protection from that.
But he introduced his own form of problems
and he unleashed it's own form of,
of dangerous and,
and potential,
potentially very despotic
arrangements of power.
And some ways are more insidious
because they appeal to bourgeoisie.
The left is always been a little
bit culturally as strange,
you know, from, from
mainstream of American life.
Whereas Trump connects
very closely with it.
This is why fascist movements have been
oftentimes much more successful than,
than left socialist
once I got to get this,
because I would have thought the opposite.
So if you,
if you would have asked
me before you said that,
I would say the left is the one that
is understood the culture part of this,
at least in the American piece of this.
Certainly academia and culture,
what you could and couldn't joke
about that all agriculture. Yeah,
the left is as high except you know,
I mean,
socialist ideology never came from below.
It was never working man's philosophy.
It was always an mental, I was always the
intellectual. So it was a top down rule.
There's always the ruling class that
hatched associates, socialist ideology.
They never would have been.
It's communism, socialism,
all these things without the
intellectual class. But fascism,
if you'll allow me to use that term, uh,
kind of flips the narrative a little bit.
It's more, it's much more of a from
below that you can keep your religion,
you can keep your nationhood, your
identity, your race, your language,
rally around your friends,
your family, you know,
all the things that you believe are
true. You and, and, and, and, and,
and within me as a person,
as a leader, I will,
I will embody all your values and
collected by us in a way that that means
something important, that, that connects
with who you are. So in that sense,
it's a very effective, uh,
way of being in liberal.
All right?
So all that said,
what is our way out of this
precarious position? I,
I think I get what you're yeah,
I get the theme of what you're doing here.
I have is we have to just keep fighting
for what we [inaudible] be better. Well,
so Dave,
I think we need to rethink who we are.
I think we need to deepen and enrich
our understanding of who we are and what
we're here to do. And it
goes back centuries. I mean,
it was the liberalism.
That dog is out of feudalism that ended
the guilds that brought us free trade,
that ended slavery,
that really gave bursts and modern world.
And we need to learn to take credit
for that and make that ethos our ethos.
Go back and read the works of Adam
Smith and the greatest cautious Scottish
enlightenment thinkers,
you know,
and and understand our history so
we understand ourselves better.
I think this is important because maybe
it stopped thinking of ourselves even
though we are radicals. I
think you are. I think I am.
I almost believe that we should
stop thinking of ourselves that way.
We should think of ourselves as normal.
If I'm a radical,
then the phrase radical, it's definitely
not as cool as it used to. I mean,
I think I'm open to these
ideas and I w I guess being,
being open right now and lit,
being really living up to the ideals that
you've set forth here is radical these
days.
It kind of is.
And maybe liberalism has always been a
radical creed because it opposes power.
It always been opposed to power.
And that's what we have to do now.
But we also have to celebrate
regular life. You know, we have to,
we have to celebrate the good life and
the beautiful things and the things we
love,
the people we love in the choices that
we can make and the technologies we can
use. And I, I fall in love with the new
technology. Every single day I came over,
I came over to see you.
Or with this new funny pillow
that I bought for $10 on Amazon,
it allows me to sleep, sitting and
stayed up. But I'm been raptured by that.
I think this is the way to happiness
and I think ultimately is the path to
political victory for us to,
to be, to be more hopeful,
to be more cheerful,
to be more,
to celebrate life and celebrate love
and celebrate wealth in a way in which
neither left or the
right or doing right now,
it gives us as an opening to be awesome,
to emancipate the world.
We can do this.
I've got nothing better to do
for more on Jeffrey.
Follow him on Twitter. Jeffrey, a talker.